what's the deal with airplane peanuts
are you sitting next to you you used to
can i sit next to him let me say next i
don't want you're gonna that's
continuity you're messing up everything
no i'm gonna watch me standing
when i would walk into the club you
would
you would go
you'd go hey
fire penis
go fetch me some [ __ ]
and i would have to go fetch you [ __ ]
didn't this [ __ ] [ __ ] right here
it's like pippy longstocking right
look at how dirty these jeans are
congratulations on everything thank you
bobby no don't do that no just give me a
hug but don't physically attack me
because you're stronger and it hurts me
sometimes i won't physically attack you
son of a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
cut down hey bro i might i think i broke
i know
thanks for watching so i have just one
more gripe oh god here we go get it out
there
i am just so sick and tired of your
[ __ ] playlist it's just all
white
sad emo rich boys with [ __ ] three
chords on a guitar
it's always talking about being in a
room and it's all the same they all
sound the same and it's always just
white
sad
rich boy singing i'll tell you why
defendant
can i tell you why defend it please
thank you thank you so much all you
relate to
order in the court
i said order in the court you shall not
do that
i'm an upper middle class white boy that
i bought i can show you right all the
movies and art that kalila has turned me
on to that i would 100 admit that she
did she's influenced my life and so many
of us i have no idea and if you look it
up on paper right who's influenced to
and who's more open to who
i think i would win that dude
i really do because i have proof all
right
i'm you know the
the thing in the bell what's that movie
the queen the bell
you keep referring to the same and only
movie you've ever watched that i
recommended no i said oh my god it's so
crazy that you name other one
bell um
the the motors which one was that one
with the a motorcycle one with the two
mexicans
motorcycle yeah what is it
motorcycles hold on that's not what i
recommend it to you you watch that on
your own probably no no we saw it i
remember
and you wikipedia did to life to get out
of it
you were like oh is it the one where
they the dogs fight but that was
[Music]
you
clever
happy father's day daddy
daddy
daddy i miss you
why are you dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry i took photos of you while you
were dead
and sent it to the heart says what was
in my head
were dead and i whipped out my
phone
i can't [ __ ] believe i did that [ __ ]
i'm all alone
daddy i love you not just incidentally
in china
there was seven guys that stabbed 138
people at a train station how did you
get to that many i know exactly what's
up with the 138th guy
no warning
he just i mean i think you're the 103rd
he walked right up to us you know i mean
a stab you know
you know i mean a guy with a knife what
are you doing sir
you're stabbing everybody yeah yeah
you're the one yeah you're dead
yeah that is a good point he just
watches the [ __ ] is your [ __ ] deal
for sure run run
first person out yeah let me just tell
you if i was there 137 people got
stabbed
right because
me i'm out bobby lee survives i survive
yeah yeah unless like i have like if my
son simon's there
then i would say
basically what it is is when you're
around other freaky reds
yeah and so you don't but i i was never
surrounded by freaky korean dudes you
know i was always surrounded by freaky
whites so hey we're surrounded by like
freaky freaky koreans my parents you
mean mm-hmm if you ever [ __ ] call my
parents freaky again i swear to [ __ ]
god dude all right i'm gonna get a diet
coke before we start your energy needs
to change you get it going
go get your coke
go get your diet coke
your energy needs to change your energy
needs this change what
i came in here you were all [ __ ] no
hellos nothing said hello no you're like
in your own world or whatever you've
been working on the show that you're on
with me
looking up the computer get your [ __ ]
thing stop done get your thing
it's gonna be a good one i'm taking your
[ __ ] i'm taking your [ __ ] butt
don't
give me this [ __ ] thing no don't
seriously don't no no no no
that's dangerous i'm serious
back up there put it on the safety what
don't
don't point it i want this put it down
i'm i'm gonna shoot you with this put it
down put this back back up put the
safety on back up put that back up dude
i swear to
it's not god on safety you could [ __ ]
hurt someone real bad don't you back up
then i will not shoot it if you come if
i have a boundary
do not cross the boundary put it on the
desk i will shoot you with it if you
don't [ __ ] sit down put it on the
desk put it away from you put it away
from you no no no put the safety on no
i'm not keeping the safety on yes
no dude
i'm leaving i'm not going to record
today i will not shoot you i promise you
never talk again that will [ __ ] yeah you
know how dangerous that is all right sit
down then don't give me no i will not oh
my god sit down
i will shoot you put the safety
just sit down point that at me and don't
do that all right well then just sit
down i won't no
don't don't talk about safeties don't
talk about safeties don't talk about
safeties oh my god don't talk about
safety don't point that at me ever again
i won't i will you put it at me no i
didn't huh no pretending yuma style no i
you walked in and i showed you the gun
all right i showed you the video you
shoot my [ __ ] hat give me the gun
here i will shoot your redheaded face
pointed at me get back on the [ __ ]
back don't pull back put it right here
no i'm not gonna put it there put it
here i need to protect myself hold on
just give me the thing no no no no no no
no no give it to me why you get so angry
because that can [ __ ] really do
damage i'm not going to hurt you i need
to put the safety on no just sit down
let's start the podcast i will not
[ __ ] do it give it to put it put it
down it's fine give me it okay i will
shoot your head if your attitude doesn't
change look i'm being 100 serious with
you i'm 100 serious as well if you shoot
me with that gun yeah if you [ __ ]
shoot me yeah i'm i'm i'm dead serious
i'm dead serious my my hands these hands
will [ __ ] pummel your stupid face
until it's city silly putty i will knock
all your teeth out i'll stomp your
[ __ ] neck in i'll beat the living
[ __ ] out of you interesting if you shoot
me in the face with that yeah you're
[ __ ] okay look at me in the eyes
you're [ __ ] if you if i shoot you in
the head with this yeah and you beat the
[ __ ] on me yeah you're [ __ ] why
you'll see why because i you think that
this is the only weapon that i have
right now that's my gun i have i know
i have other weapons as well give me my
gun no let me just have it no bobby
you'll get it at the end of the podcast
i want it all right let me ask you
another um question may i mm-hmm if i
shoot you in the head
if you shoot me in the head let me just
follow this through please
and you beat the living [ __ ] out of me
listen
would you end this podcast forever
you swear to god if you shot me in the
[ __ ] head yeah with a with an airsoft
gun yeah those are rock hard bbs yeah
yeah they're not even the plastic ones
right i would beat the living [ __ ] out
of you and then i'd make you do a
podcast with me and that would be our
final podcast
i'd make you do one all [ __ ] up yeah
yeah and bleeding and dripping and no
teeth yeah and me with a bullet can i
shoot george
yeah okay
yeah don't point it at people i'm not
gonna throw it i'm looking my hands not
even on the trigger dude it's supposed
to be on the side
it's just gonna be on your your trigger
finger should be on the side of the gun
like this don't point it at me like this
like this yes okay put the safety on
i'll put the safety on you don't know
how
you have to pull back on those things
and
it's not on
s it's a little s
no dude
it's not on look i'm gonna show you yes
put it up now put it away put it down
okay
that's it now the safety is off you just
turn it off again it says s
with the red that's f it's gonna fire
right now okay
it's not gonna fire okay good point
point it at the point shoot the plant
shoot the shoot the plant
yeah okay good
[Laughter]
no no no touch my hand
all right
right but maybe your focus is um
elsewhere but the podcast
i just you need to get one eye my career
this is your career too yeah it's part
of it yeah that's a big part of it
okay okay
you're being very confrontational
that's a good question for you yeah yeah
is this something that we can consider a
career what we do to me podcasters to me
to me yeah
it's becoming more real as the days go
by
okay because i go out there
right as a journeyman as a prophet of
sorts
right to touch the people
right i hug him
cheek to cheek body the body
energy exchange you try to say you're
jesus no i didn't say that
but i do have a um
a line up to somebody okay and um the
line is directed to me and i i'm a
vessel the co dakota access pipeline the
god that's what i would exactly call it
thank you
that's exactly what i'm saying and um
i feel that you're very talented look at
me right on my eyes
you're getting fat stuck it at the tip
of oh my god it's still there now bob
what but it's your glass
yeah it's my booger it was already
inside my body i know so get it out get
it away get it out no no if i stick it
back inside my body who cares it's where
it belongs
what so no yeah boogers are gross to me
why i don't know i don't know why i just
they yucky i don't like that stuff
you've never eaten it
you eat your boogers
do you really eat your boogers
i have when was the last time you had a
booger
when was the last time
you ate a booger
you know it's when was the last let me
let me go back though for a second just
give me a second i want to answer i i
will give you an answer
i'm going to give you a [ __ ] answer
all right but i'm going to tell you
something yeah there are things in
people's lives private lives right what
you do in secret right and you're in
your good one it happens enough that you
don't remember
what it happens enough that you don't
remember
it happens often enough that you don't
remember
oh in my lifetime you're asking me it
must happen regularly that you don't
remember yeah i don't remember
so maybe
a couple of days ago
no no i would have remembered a couple
days ago but maybe a week within the
month within the month within the month
have you ever eaten a booger root no
no no no never never but have you ever
pulled out a booger and rolled it for a
while yeah i've rolled it for a while
so
what what does the booger taste like to
you
i don't know i've never tasted it what
do i think it tastes like
mucus
with the flavor though what's the flavor
yeah
uh uh
funyuns
no
uh salty okay onions are very salty
that's exactly what they are yeah like
oniony chips salty you've eaten a booger
before man no man i roll up yeah you
you've eaten a [ __ ] booger before it
got in my life sort of gotta have now
that's ridiculous i would never i the
look of it is gross to me i've tried
everything off my body i mean i wouldn't
even eat like mushrooms until i was you
know 30. sperm
never
never you've never tasted your own sperm
nope
nope wow me either yeah
i haven't either
you've tasted your own sperm and other
people's
yep don't be like that is that not true
don't say it like that tell me is it
true
have i tasted other people's [ __ ] yeah
yes four three two one come santa claus
here comes santa claus he'll come here
he
here is here he is
he is fan big and he he loves you
in christmas
welcome to another i don't even know
when this comes out but i think it feels
coming out christmas christmas yeah yeah
around christmas um
my dad used to sing me christmas songs
growing up but he never knew the words
you know
how about this old classic from my dad
yeah frosty hill good guy
classic
he's laughing american yeah or he forget
the word sometimes he'll go jingle bell
jingle i don't know
fell you [ __ ] just said it
you said it just repeat it
i go back to tijuana but without the
waiters i'm trying to find that girl why
her i don't know i'm obsessed
she's the one she's the one in my life
yeah
but i go to hooker alley and she wasn't
there but at the end of hooker alley
there was a [ __ ]
albino redheaded mexican guy okay that
is too much
well he's red-headed
a dwarf and he's albino okay my name is
red-headed pigment and he was albino at
the same time it's not freckles thank
you christopher
not even impossible and he's just a
redhead sweetie
but he's mexican so he's got to be
albino what canelo
they have a lack of pigmentation right
so it would be if there's no red pigment
they could have freckle like maybe some
weird no because freckles would be
that's color too they wouldn't have
anything oh i'm sorry mrs pharmacy
school
who's a doctor
okay can i tell my [ __ ] story first
of all let me say this at pharmacy
school
you weren't there man
all right
i saw what i saw man i want you to draw
who this person looked like because he
looked like that
look at that
give me that give me that give me that
[ __ ] thing
all right
a clown
that's what i saw okay but that's not an
albino that's just a redheaded kid with
white yeah but if he's okay if i'm in
arkansas
if an arkansas it's a reddited kid yeah
mexico albino oh i see because he's
supposed to be brown yeah yeah all right
yeah put this back
okay proceed i don't like the way george
is looking at me like is this bad
so a week later but she's not there i
hook her alley but i see this guy at the
end of the heart
hey he goes
that's a good accent that's what he said
yeah i thought yeah i guess so i guess i
guess so
maybe what a poignant question thank you
i like [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i know where good pulse is
i go okay i'll go with you
like a [ __ ] idiot
yeah three weeks three blocks away we
run into another guy his buddy who's now
six two
he has tattoos to his wrist skinny
goatee yeah you like [ __ ] oh man
right i go that's what he just asked me
three blocks ago
well we're all in tune here
yeah yeah so i walked with these two
guys
nine blocks now
we're getting into part of tijuana where
there's no street lights three-legged
dogs tumbleweed
and now i know i'm gonna die
you know
so
they go hey
go down this alleyway this is where the
[ __ ] is yeah so i walked this
alleyway the [ __ ]
runs down the alley as fast as he can
i'm like where the [ __ ] is he running to
neverland where the [ __ ] is he going
and i get slammed against the wall
a brick wall and a machete from the tall
guys from his ankle
he just pulls this thing out
and he sticks it to my neck
he goes give me your money
so i pull out my money
i give it to him
so i give it to him puts it back in his
pocket and he's about to now slice my
head off i swear to [ __ ] god
he has it so deep into my neck
like you could feel the pressure
and i started laughing
you really laughed i really did because
i knew i was gonna die
and i know now that if i'm ever gonna
die i'm gonna laugh
which is a good thing
if i ever see my death if i'm on a plane
it's going down i'm gonna go
you know i'm gonna laugh and and also i
the laughter was also
guilt for like because my parents you
know like they're not gonna find my
[ __ ] body
they're not gonna find my head it's
gonna be a mystery where did bobby go
for the rest of their lives it's a
little [ __ ] up
but then what i hear is i see screaming
on the other side of this hall this this
alleyway
right and these two other guys emerge
who i've never seen before it's not the
dwarf dwarf i've never seen the dwarf
again
and these these guys are like
screaming at this other guy about like
money
so apparently if what i gathered was
through just the arguments like they
want a piece of the action
because it's their alleyway
so now my wallet is now on the ground in
a puddle
right so while they're arguing i grab my
wallet and i start running
oh [ __ ]
now i got three guys chasing me
okay in the darkness
and i'm this is i swear to god i go in
my head i'm like if i get through this
number one i'll never come back down
here
and number two i'll start doing stand up
which took me two years
to do it
but i did it
so i started running through these
streets and then eventually i see
a pic pink awning
and a red door it's obviously a bar
and the door just kind of swings open
and about 25 to 30 african-american
marines
come out of this [ __ ] place
wow
right so i run toward them
and i go hey you know i'm an american
these guys are trying to kill me they
took my money
and all like marines walked like looked
at my direction
and you could see the three guys running
the other way
and then two of these guys and if you're
ever listening to these two guys thank
you
walk me to the border
and i got my toyota whatever camera i
had
and i went home
saw the story whoa and then that was 21
and at 23 i started doing stand up
swing baby swing yeah swing and i'm
going to do that right in your face like
that boom
yeah look at this takedown take down
baby
i'm on top of i'm on top baby
oh
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] get off your back
yo hobo sorry hey guys first of all
that was homo i didn't want him to do
that i didn't mean to [ __ ] him i'm a
very big supporter of the lgbt
communities when i say homo i don't mean
it in a negative way i don't mean in a
republican way but that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
[ __ ] but i love ellen boom look at that
kicks
oh [ __ ]
as he takes his fight down johnny
hendrix
man put him in a [ __ ] thing
[Music]
you